I want to start dr. Lipton and Shannon
with a photo that a korean couple took
it was a wedding photo where everyone
was wearing surgical masks because of
the concern over MERS this was a bit of
a joke it was meant as such but of
course there's some underlying truth to
all of this what is the chain of events
that happens if Merce does turn into
something like SARS are we there yet
Shannon well that's probably unlikely
and dr. Lipman can explain a little bit
more the science behind that and people
wearing face masks around town might be
a bit of an exaggeration at this point
because MERS is not spread as easily as
SARS MERS from what we know and we don't
know that much about it because it's
still relatively new virus but it
requires close contact and most of
people who've been infected our health
care workers or family members of those
who are infected so it's not something
you're going to get on the subway
necessarily on an airplane or at a
wedding party so right now it seems like
so the fear and anxiety is a little bit
over the top compared to what the
reality is an infection but yeah maybe
dr. lookin can explain a little bit more
what the true risk is to people at this
point well no you know these viruses can
change and that it can become more
transmissible but at present this virus
is not as transmissible as was SARS so I
think all those masks are definitely
over the top on the other hand the virus
is transmitted through the air and if
you have very close contact with people
were infected as has happened in
hospitals and other very tight quarters
there is concern now Africa and Asia
have tended to be the sources of new
pathogens if you're looking at stars or
Ebola not necessarily the Middle East
because of that do we have less
information to work with and as a result
is MERS a bigger unknown than previous
infectious diseases that captured our
attention I think you've raised an
interesting question we don't know a
great deal about infectious diseases in
the Middle East and this is a major
concern because you have mass gatherings
there you have millions of pilgrims who
go to Saudi Arabia annually from all
over the world I thought Tober exactly
and as they become ill they return to
their home countries and they can carry
infectious agents with them I was in
Saudi Arabia last week the Saudi Arabian
government takes this very seriously and
they are
interested in developing a very strong
surveillance program to reduce this risk
for themselves as well as for the world
at large now according to the world
health organization though there was not
a single case attributed to the
pilgrimage does that mean that we
presume transmission just isn't that
easy it's probably going to be something
that required some sort of close contact
now sort of you know walking past people
it you know one thing that is
interesting here is that you know as you
mentioned this is a disease that's been
you know isolated mostly to Saudi Arabia
there's been about four hundred deaths
most of those in the Middle East at this
point but it's just a reminder as we saw
an Ebola vet all of these viruses that
we think are far away in overseas and
don't affect us in this global connected
world there really a plane ride away and
you know that's why we everyone sort of
needs to be vigilant and paying
attention to the to these and and not
really think that the US or Korea or
Europe is immune to anything that's
happening in Africa and Asia that things
are so transmissible so quickly we
learned that in Ebola we're seeing that
again here we have had a couple cases of
MERS in the United States as well it
didn't really spread through you know as
it has in Korea but it's it's sort of a
cautionary sign the feel is very
different from a bullet when there is
just this mass panic the wh 0 has met to
discuss MERS I think eight times since
for life 2013 each time it has decided
not to label it as a global public
health emergency dr. Lucan is that a
good thing when it comes to
understanding the disease and educating
the public I don't think we can on an
every other month basis declare a global
infectious disease emergency people stop
paying attention Ebola was far more
dangerous than his murders murders has a
case fatality rate of about ten percent
Ebola was much higher excuse me emerged
is actually higher it's got actually
close to forty percent SARS had a lower
case fatality rate about ten percent but
it was highly infectious so I don't have
the same sort of response tumors that I
have dis ours I was in China during SARS
it completely overwhelmed
that particular community at that point
ana bola obviously had devastating
consequences in West Africa and I think
there's going to be fallout economic and
otherwise from this in Korea and in
China if definitely if you think if the
Korean government is able to quarantine
people isolated use proper infection
control will this just burn out on its
own I see Korea yes I think they should
burn out of its own accord but as you've
already said there's the potential for
this to merge and re-emerge continuously
because unlike some of these other
infections we worry about this one has
an animal reservoir yeah and it
percolates up in the human population
then it goes human human